mehr Fortschritt Wagen unter dieser
Überschrift trat die Ampelkoalition
genau vor einem Jahr den Dienst an jetzt
heißt es Krieg und Krisen ertragen die
zeitenwände ein einziger Stress-Test für
SPD Grüne und FDP Mindestlohn Bürgergeld
fachkräfteeinwanderung Entlastung bei
Energiepreisen die Bundesregierung hat
einiges auf den Weg gebracht die Bürger
zeigen sich aber trotzdem in der
Mehrheit unzufrieden ein Jahr
Ampelkoalition wie schlägt sich das
Krisenbündnis unser Thema in der Phönix
[Musik]
Runde
guten Abend herzlich willkommen aus
Berlin ich darf hier meine Gäste
vorstellen bei uns ist Christoph
schwennecke Publizist und Autor und
ehemaliger Chefredakteur des Ciceros und
ich begrüße ihnen es Schwertner
Publizistin und Chefredakteurin der
deutschsprachigen Ausgabe des
sozialistischen Magazins jacobyn und
Autoren für die tats und herzlich
willkommen Daniel brößler leitender
Redakteur in der parlamentsredaktion der
Süddeutschen Zeitung und da zuständig
fürs Kanzleramt und zugeschaltet ist uns
Livia Gerster sie ist politikredakteurin
der Frankfurter Allgemeinen
Sonntagszeitung und in ihrem gerade
erschienen Buch die neuen da beschreibt
sie was die jungen Abgeordneten so
umtreibt ja schauen wir auf diese
Ampelkoalition und auch auf ein Jahr
Bundeskanzler Scholz ist ja auch eine
wichtige Frage wie er dieses Land so
führt und regiert Herr schwennige wenn
sie so noch mal denken so ein Jahr Ampel
gibt's da so einen stärksten Moment für
Sie
also den einen Moment an den kann ich
nicht erinnern ich bin dankbar wenn die
Kolleginnen oder Kollegen ja hast du
zeitenwände ja aber das weiß kein Moment
sondern mehr ein Wort ja aber war es ein
richtiger Moment ich weiß es nicht also
das hat aber meine erinnerungsschwäche
hat vielleicht auch damit zu tun dass
das dass das dass die Regierung ein sehr
sehr ruhigen
Regierungsstil hat
der damit einhergeht dass vielleicht
auch die Umfragewerte nicht so toll sind
also ich würde zwei
Gründe dafür ausmachen wobei ich sage
die Umfrage gewesen in dem Fall ehrlich
gesagt schlechter als die Leistung also
meine meine meine Leistungsbilanz wäre
besser als die Umfragen
kannst du Scholz ist nicht der stärkste
Kommunikator und wenn er was wenn er
redet dann sagt er nicht viel und er
redet schon wenig und das ganze wird
dann ab und zu noch unterbrochen von so
von so Arroganz Attacken kann immer
wieder auftreten die aber dann wiederum
zu dem wenigen reden sonst nicht so
richtig passen und da bin ich offen
gestanden selber überrascht hätte ich
anders eingeschätzt
gelb und grün hat richtig große Probleme
miteinander es war ja die haben da eine
Party gemacht und gesagt Mensch wir
haben uns erst mal so richtig kennen und
schätzen gelernt und es wirkt er auch
authentisch das kann auch persönlich auf
der persönlichen Ebene so sein aber in
der inhaltlichen Ebene sind die
ideologischen Unterschiede doch sehr
sehr groß angesprochen was wir noch
vertiefen müssen also Zeiten Wände die
Rede von Scholz weil ihr stärkster
Moment ich finde schon dass das auch ein
Moment war und nicht nur ein Wort im
Bundestag am 27 Februar diese Rede war
schon eine starke Rede und es war ja
auch eine Ansage es war eine Ansage
Verstand zu haben was passiert ist und
daraus Konsequenzen zu ziehen das war im
Bundestag durchaus beeindruckend und das
hat die Latte natürlich sehr hoch
gehängt also die Frage war ja was wird
aus all dem Folgen äh Scholz hat
eigentlich überrascht als jemand der
tatsächlich in der Krise
entscheidungsfreudig ist und alles was
danach passiert ist ist glaube ich muss
ich daran messen lassen und da ist er
natürlich dann außerdem geblieben
zumindest zeitweise unter dem was er
eigentlich selber mit dieser Zeitenwende
Rede versprochen hat das dann nicht so
eingelöst wurden die Erwartung ist
erfüllt wie geht es Ihnen damit ich
glaube genau das spricht eigentlich für
die gesamte für das gesamte erste Jahr
der Koalition weil ja schon diese
Ankündigung der fortschrittskoalition
sehr vollmundig war und genauso wie die
zeitenwände genauso wie der doppelwumms
also an großen Begriffen wurde
eigentlich nicht gespart im
Pressekonferenzen aber eben was danach
dabei rumgekommen ist muss man sagen ist
eigentlich ziemlich wenig Fortschritt
und auch gleichzeitig nicht wirklich der
Doppelpunkt zumindest kommt er bei den
Menschen nicht an sonst würden ja die
Umfragen auch nicht so schlecht sein
also gleichzeitig wird sehr viel Geld in
die Hand genommen und auch natürlich auf
eine Krise reagiert aber eben ständig
reagiert und tatsächlich überhaupt nicht
den Fortschritt von alleine so
angeschoben wie er angekündigt war
vor Gerster was ist ihr stärkster Moment
wenn sie zurückblicken auf dieses Jahr
ja ich würde auch sagen die Zeitenwende
redet das Kanzlers war das weil da
einfach mit
einer jahrzehntelangen verfehlten
russland-politik gebrochen wurde es hat
ja lang genug gedauert also man kann
sich ja kaum noch daran erinnern wie im
Januar Februar vor dem Überfall Scholz
das Wort Nord Stream zum Beispiel gar
nicht in den Mund nehmen konnte und dann
plötzlich wurde aber eben umgedacht kann
man sagen zu spät aber die Kehrtwende
wurde eben vollzogen und auch wenn es
danach dann wieder langsamer ging und
wir uns dann gestritten haben über
schwere und leichte Waffen und einige
unsinnige Diskussionen auch geführt
haben finde ich muss man schon sagen und
der Regierung zugestehen dass diese
Kehrtwende einfach vollzogen wurde und
korrigiert wurde
also ich glaube wir alle unabhängig
davon wie alt wir jeweils sind können
uns nicht erinnern an eine Regierung die
unter so extremen Bedingungen ins Amt
starten musste also klar 98 war für
Rot-Grün auch hart weil auch ganz
schnell der Balkan kriegt dann auch mit
eigener militärischer direkte
Beteiligung stattfand das hat auch viel
abverlangt von Anfang an aber das hier
also mitten in einer Pandemie dann
obendrein noch diesen Ukraine Krieg zu
bekommen das war kein Sprung ins kalter
Wasser das vereistauchen von Anfang an
und ich finde auch das muss man bei
einer fairen
Beurteilung berücksichtigen das ist ja
auch die Frage was ist der was ist der
Maßstab stimmt zwar dass bei den
Menschen die Entlastungen vielleicht
noch nicht in dem Maß angekommen sind
aber wenn wir uns jetzt die Situation
anschauen
wir haben anders als erwartet keinen
heißen Protest Herbst erlebt wir haben
keine Situation
riesiger soziale Unruhen wir haben keine
schweren wirtschaftlichen Verwerfungen
in dem Sinne dass jetzt rein Weise
Unternehmen pleite gehen würden das ist
angesichts der Situation des anhalten im
Krieges der dramatischen
weltwirtschaftlichen Lage ja eigentlich
schon ein Erfolg also ich glaube wir
müssen einfach schauen was ist der
Maßstab und in einer Situation wo wir
vielleicht alle gemeinsam vor ein paar
Monaten gesagt hätten im Dezember werden
wir frieren das tun wir nicht
wir haben Protest Herbst oder vorher
herausgesagt die Industrialisierung
wurde ganz Europa
durch den Winter kommen es sieht so aus
dass zumindest die schlimmsten Härten
abgefedert werden können das wäre jetzt
von einem Jahr nichts gewesen wo wir
sagen das ist eine volksbilanz aber in
der Lage in der wir sind muss man glaube
ich schon in Rechnung stellen es könnte
schlimmer sein die sagen jetzt kommt die
nicht genug an also was kritisieren sie
nicht genau also vielleicht noch mal zu
der Zeitenwende also die bedeutet ja
nicht einfach nur eine Abkehr von der
Politik gegen Russland oder von der
Energieabhängigkeit sondern bedeutet ja
eben auch die 100 Milliarden sonder
mögen Dir quasi schon mal am Anfang des
gesetzt haben und gezeigt haben man kann
über Nacht ein Sondervermögen in
dreistelliger Milliardenhöhe plötzlich
möglich machen das sind Christian
Lindner Olaf Scholz mehr oder weniger
vorbei gemacht auch an den Koalitionären
an ihren Parteien das war eigentlich der
interessanteste Bruch da dran und danach
hat man gemerkt okay es kann so große
Pakete geben einerseits für die größte
Militarisierung dieses Landes seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg und gleichzeitig gab
es zu wenige soziale entlastungspakete
also die haben im Vergleich das erste
war 30 Milliarden Euro das zweite dann
65 Milliarden Euro blieben weiter hinter
zurück ähm muss man sagen und in dem
zweiten Entlastungspaket waren Dinge die
schon längst im Koalitionsvertrag
festgeschrieben waren also Mindestlohn
Bürgergeld und so weiter das waren bis
dahin keine großen Entlastung das erste
wirklich Entlastungspaket sind jetzt die
200 Milliarden Euro für die
gaspreisbremse die aber auch nur
gekommen ist weil man musste und weil
vorher die ganzen Lage man erinnert sich
bis zum letzten Tag eigentlich aufrecht
wurde dir die Preise komplett an die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger weitergegeben
hätte also der die Entlastung kam zu
spät und sie kommen auch jetzt viel zu
spät und man musste jetzt ganz lange
diskutieren das überhaupt die
gaspreisbremse erst im März kommen
sollte
und sie kommt immer noch zu spät
das ist ja nicht so dass dann nur in
Anführungszeichen für die Bundeswehr 100
Milliarden ausgegeben oder ein Aussicht
gestellt wurden sind ja noch nicht mal
ausgeben erstmal sind das große chiffrin
die erstmal auch hinterlegt werden
müssen sie haben die Zahlen genannt die
im anderen Zusammenhang da auch an die
Wand geworfen würden ich stürmisch
ehrlich gesagt ein wenig an den Begriff
wenn Sie erlauben Militarisierung und
das hat millilitarisierung nun wirklich
nichts zu tun es war höchste Zeit dass
das die Bundeswehr die wirklich auf der
Felge war die auf die Felge gespart war
wieder einigermaßen Asur gemacht noch
nicht sein wird und wenn jetzt nicht
entschuldigen
aber nicht besser aber das anzukündigen
und zu sagen wir haben da enorme
Nachholbedarf das muss man nicht schön
finden dass unterhalten so sind aber
diese dieses diese Armee kann in diesem
Zustand in einer solchen Bedrohungslage
nicht bleiben und deswegen würde ich das
nicht Militarisierung sondern notwendige
Modernisierung der Streitkräfte nennen
Frau gersta wie würden Sie sagen sehen
das war ja im umstritten es war auch ich
habe es ja anfangs gesagt dass sie sich
mit vielen jungen Abgeordneten
unterhalten haben und das sind ja auch
extrem viel mehr junge Abgeordneter als
in den letzten Legislaturperioden jetzt
im Bundestag
die sind ja dann neu in den Bundestag
gekommen was hat das eigentlich mit
denen gemacht dass dann auf einmal über
so viele große Themen abgestimmt werden
musste
naja das hat natürlich ihre Pläne
durchkreuzt also die kamen ja ins
Parlament um das Klima zu retten zum
Beispiel die Jungen Grünen oder um
Sozialpolitik zu machen endlich für
gleiche Chancen zu sorgen für alle und
dann hat natürlich der Krieg diese Pläne
durchkreuzt aber ich würde sagen sie
haben sehr schnell umgedacht und wenn
Frau Schwertner von der Militarisierung
spricht das ist ja was was bei der bei
den Usus oder bei der Grünen Jugend auch
immer so das Wort war was man verwandt
hat und ich finde da haben sie aber sehr
gut sehr schnell ihre eigenen Vorurteile
gegenüber der Bundeswehr wie Dirt und
vor allen Dingen auch schneller und
gedacht als Mann störrische ältere wie
wenn man einen Rolf Mütze nicht denkt in
der SPD der ja ähm der noch heute in den
Trümmern seines Weltbildes sucht nach
irgendetwas was heil geblieben ist dann
finde ich haben die jungen da natürlich
unbelastet von der Vergangenheit sie
haben diese Russland Politik eben nicht
gemacht aber eben waren diejenigen die
Druck gemacht haben von Anfang an bei
Waffenlieferungen die nach Sanktion
gerufen haben als ähm eben wirklich
einige ältere da noch lange nicht so
weit heißt dass die größer die der Krieg
und alles das was ich dadurch geändert
hat war letztendlich auch für die
Koalition ja doch ein Hilfsmittel das
klingt jetzt so merkwürdig aber hat der
hat letztendlich die Koalition doch
zusammengeschweißt dass das merkwürdig
klingt ich glaube dass das tatsächlich
so ist ich bin mir nämlich nicht sicher
ob wenn es die Krise nicht gegeben hätte
wenn es den Krieg nicht gegeben hätte
wir heute eine stabilere Koalition
hätten ich glaube dass dieser
fürchterliche Krieg eine
disziplinierende Wirkung hat auch wenn
es so scheint zwischendurch mal dass die
Koalition nicht so wahnsinnig
diszipliniert ist aber ich glaube es
gibt diese Wirkung weil eins ja klar ist
es ist völlig unmöglich in dieser
Situation diese Koalition zu verlassen
keiner kann das tun das wäre absolut
verantwortungslos es steht einfach nicht
zu Debatte ich glaube wenn man mit den
Koalitionären spricht so so schwierig
das immer im Einzelfall ist wissen sie
glaube ich im ganzen dass das nicht geht
dass das ein Flucht eine Flucht vor der
Verantwortung wäre und insofern glaube
ich dass die die weltanschaulichen
Konflikte die wir sehen die Probleme
zwischen
FDP und Grünen die wir sehen die wären
ja auch da es nur gäbe es viel mehr Zeit
sich zu streiten es gäbe es gäbe auch
glaube ich eine größere Unbeschwertheit
und jetzt ist eine Situation in der es
immer wieder zu schweren Konflikten
kommt das ist auch ganz natürlich glaube
ich weil sie eben auch ziemlich
schwierige Fragen sind aber immer
relativ klar ist dann fügt man sich eben
einem Machtwort zum Beispiel des
Bundeskanzlers das wäre im normalen
Zeiten in Anführungsstrichen glaube ich
nicht so einfach da würde man sagen das
können wir nicht mit uns machen lassen
dass der Kanzler jetzt hier die
Richtlinienkompetenz zieht also
disziplinierende wirken in so einer
Koalition dass er das schon gehört haben
wir eigentlich nicht im Grunde ist die
Richtlinienkompetenz nur dazu da dass
sie da ist und dass sie nicht benutzt
wird die atomare Option das genau
ganz anders ist alle waren ja dann ganz
glücklich dass er das gemacht hat also
was vielleicht auch nicht so
überraschend für die stationäre aber das
zeigt dass die Situation so ist und ich
würde es tatsächlich sagen es ist die
Koalitionäre selber nennen es ja jetzt
eine arbeitskoalition entsprechen nicht
mehr so sehr von fortschrittskoalition
und ich glaube so ist es die müssen die
Arbeit machen und die Arbeit ist
Krisenmanagement genau und Frau schöne
wer bewegt sich da am meisten in ihrem
Eindruck also wer muss am meisten
sozusagen ja über Hürden springen und
und denken oh jetzt muss ich doch noch
mal ein bisschen meine meine
ursprünglichen Ideen doch vielleicht
Opfern ja also ich glaube erstmal wer
sich am wenigsten bewegt die SPD oder
bzw der Kanzler der ja wirklich wie
eigentlich schon wie seine Vorgängerin
Angela Merkel das Ganze mehr oder
weniger aussieht und zwischengesetz
relativ wenig kommuniziert die SPD
erfüllt die ihre Wahlversprechen und gut
ist also nicht mehr nicht weniger aber
tatsächlich wäre am meisten im schreit
miteinander so ist sind FDP und ähm
grüne und ich glaube sie geben sich da
immer wieder so gegenseitig ihre
Päckchen in die Hand also ob sie sich
ideologisch tatsächlich so weit
auseinander sind da bin ich mir gar
nicht so sicher weil jetzt zum Beispiel
auch wieder bei der gaspreisbremse waren
dann habe ich und Lindner gar nicht so
weit weg voneinander was zum Beispiel
die Industrie an ging da war die SPD
wesentlich stärker und war viel stärker
darauf bedacht auch diese Rückwirkungen
zum Beispiel früher vorzuziehen das
heißt in diesen ganzen Energie
technischen Dingen würde ich sagen sind
Habeck und Lindner gar nicht so weit
voneinander weg und das Interessanteste
ist eigentlich dass die FDP ein bisschen
der Schizophrene Rolle einnimmt also
weil sie natürlich ihre Ideologie
Eingriffe sein aber die diese Regierung
muss das eigentlich permanent tun und
sie muss Schulden machen
sie muss eigentlich
verstaatlichen also sie muss eine
gaspreisbremse sie muss in den Markt
eigentlich so dermaßen Eingreifen das
könnte eine FDP im Grunde mit ihren
ganzen Überzeugung überhaupt nicht ähm
die nehmen sich ja ich glaube dass die
FDP tatsächlich den schwersten stand in
dieser Koalition als ich hätte vermutet
dass es rot gelb mit grünem Anhang
werden könnte es Rot-Grün mit gelbem
Anhang geworden deswegen strampelt die
FDP auch mehr als die Grünen das tut ihr
dann auch nicht gut das Strampeln wird
nämlich auch nicht gutiert sondern wird
so ein bisschen als beleidigt oder als
schwach angesehen ich wollte noch eines
sagen zu dem was Daniel Brüssel sagt und
eins zu dem was Frau Schwertner sagte
ich das ich sehe es auch so der der die
inneren Fliehkräfte sind in Wahrheit
groß aber der äußere Druck der ist
zusammenhält ist noch größer das ist
genau die Situation in der sich diese
Koalition befindet und manchmal bleibt
leider und daneben die sich in meinen
Augen nichts die Grünen und die gelben
so nenne ich jetzt mal bleibt leider das
Gute oder das bessere auf der Strecke
was eigentlich so naheliegend wäre ist
bleibt für mich eine eine eine
schreckliche Sache das das was jeder
normale Mensch sagen würde lasst uns
doch das Tempolimit jetzt bis auf
weiteres auf deutschen Autobahnen
einführen das gab es übrigens schon mal
in der Ölkrise in den 70er Jahren
diese drei Atom Stadtwerke auch noch bis
auf weiteres weiterlaufen ich glaube
dass beide Maßnahmen der Sache gedient
hätten aber natürlich in den jeweiligen
Lagern ein No-Go waren und das ist
letztlich dann will man sich doch nicht
ganz so weit bewegen wie sehen sie es
dann also nur für einen höheren Preis
jetzt so klein nicht
gefundenkraftwerke nicht nur diese drei
Monate oder zwei drei Monate
gewesen Frau Gerster ja da kriegt eben
wirklich dann jede Partei was sie will
die FDP ihren Tankrabatt die Grünen ist
9 € Ticket auch wenn es sich dann
gegenseitig widerspricht und das ist
natürlich schon eine große Diskrepanz zu
dem zu dem Anspruch den man hatte also
mit diesem grünen gelb glitzernden
selfie mit dem was anfing und der
fortschrittskoalition und dass man eben
nicht in diesen groko-modus will wo man
sich immer nur auf den kleinsten
gemeinsamen Nenner einigt und wenn man
ehrlich ist ist man aber genau da jetzt
angekommen dass man eben alle Konflikte
mit Geld zu schüttet und eben statt
einer Vision diesen den ganzen
gemeinsamen Nenner hat
als ich nur interessant finde ist dass
wir gar nicht über das reden was was
eigentlich doch erstmal entscheidend ist
und entscheidend und das muss man dieser
Koalition schon anrechnen ist die
Haltung zu diesem Krieg und auch die
Reaktionen auf diesen Krieg das war ja
nicht selbstverständlich das vergisst
man jetzt vielleicht aber dass die SPD
dahin kommt und sagt wir wir sind und
auch die Grünen wir sind wir sind wir
sind bereit und halten das auch für
notwendig Waffen in die Ukraine zu
liefern wir
wir haben eine ganz klare Haltung zu
diesem Krieg und wir bekennen auch dass
die Russland Politik vollkommen verfehlt
war das ist schon ein Bruch gewesen und
auch wenn man die Waffenhilfe für
anfangs zu zögerlich halten kann wenn
man darüber diskutieren kann ob es nicht
eigentlich richtig wäre jetzt
tatsächlich auch westliche Panzer zu
liefern geht grundsätzlich dass
Deutschland tatsächlich zu den wichtigen
Unterstützern der Ukraine gehört und das
ist würde ich sagen erstmal mit das
wichtigste zur Zeit tief ganz vorne mit
dabei aber kommunikativ hat man sich
ganz schnell in diese Defensivposition
bringen lassen das meinte ich eingangs
auch dass die das ist oft an der
Kommunikations fehlt natürlich ich sehe
es wie Daniel brössler da war eine ich
würde es eher Zurückhaltung erstmal
nennen da war nicht also so wie Toni
Hofreiter und agnesstra Zimmermann Marie
agnesstag Zimmermann wollten der
Bundeskanzler und die Regierung jetzt
nicht gleich liefern dafür hatte ich ein
gewisses Verständnis gebe ich zu es
wurde dann trotzdem alles gemacht und
zwar in einem in einer Dimension wo man
sich vor keinem anderen Nato-Partner
dann verstecken muss aber man warte
trotzdem den schwarzen Peter und war der
Watschen Baum mit einmal weil die
Deutschen irgendwie im Wege gestanden
der Ukraine anständig zu helfen das war
kommunikativ katastrophal gemacht durch
wen durch den Bundeskanzler vor allen
Dingen einfach mal ich finde man merkt
ihn richtig an dass er eigentlich keine
Lust hat etwas zu erklären da tritt er
in die Fußstapfen seiner Vorgängerin die
hat es auch auch nicht so sehr damit
aber er macht ja eine Sache total anders
nämlich er redet wahnsinnig viel ja aber
ohne was zu sagen das meinte ich doch
eigentlich das ist doch erstmal ein
Punkt also im Vergleich zur
Bundeskanzlerin
allein die Schlagzahl der der
Fernsehauftritte der Interviews der
Bundeskanzler geht auf Reisen und macht
kurz vorher erst als das als die Kritik
kam dass er zu wenig davon angeschalte
erst dann kam dieser umgeschaltet ich
glaube er würde gerne erklären
er hat da einfach sozusagen innere
Grenzen was was seine Fähigkeit geht
bestimmte Dinge zu erklären und das ist
das eine und das andere ist dass er
manchmal ich würde sagen
da sind so ein paar Knoten bei ihm ja
ähm das hat man ganz stark gemerkt bei
der Diskussion um Waffenlieferungen da
wollte er was andeuten dass das
eventuell zu tun haben könnte mit der
Angst vor einer nuklearen Eskalation er
war aber anfangs nicht sicher ob das
eigentlich klug wäre das zu sagen und
dann wird es eben verschworbelt und da
sind natürlich kommunikative Schwächen
und die ziehen sich dann durch alle
diese Themen über die wir reden wie
kommuniziert denn der Kanzler in
Richtung des
Fragen sogar in Richtung aus seiner
eigenen Fraktion er muss ja auch da
hören wir ja eigentlich von wenig Streit
am Anfang gab es mit mit Mütze nicht
schon nach einer Auseinandersetzung aber
jetzt wirkt es ja so als wäre alles
immer würde alles so mitgetragen ist es
so oder ist das ein falscher Eindruck
hält er bei der Stange das ist so und
das ist wahrscheinlich auch ein Motiv
hinter dieser Zögerlichkeit immer wieder
dass er da vor allen Dingen auf seine
eigene Partei guckt auch von den jungen
ich meine die 49 Jusos im Parlament die
haben ja dem einen oder anderen da auch
durchaus Angst gemacht in dem Kanzler
und vielleicht auch eine
Fraktionsvorsitzenden die Revolution
blieb dann ja aus von denen aber auch da
gab es ja anfangs Widerstand gegen die
100 Milliarden das hat er ja schon alles
ganz gut beisammen gehalten aber dennoch
die Kommunikation nach außen da würde
ich auch sagen ich meine heißt ja
inzwischen der NÖ Kanzler weil er gerne
mal mit nö antwortet wenn er gefragt
wird nach praktischen Alltagstipps und
erscheint aber auch ehrlich gesagt stolz
darauf zu sein also sonst würde es ja
nicht immer wieder machen kurz danach
oder einige Zeit danach in Ellmau wo er
dann gefragt wurde können Sie das
konkrete konkretisieren mit der Ukraine
Hilfe und er dann könnte ich das war's
sagte also da fragt man sich dann schon
was soll das ich finde das geht auch
nicht als hanseatischer Humor durch weil
diese Überheblichkeit die zeigt sich ja
immer wieder man hat einfach das Gefühl
da ist dieser Subtext ich weiß es besser
lasst mich mal machen ihr könnt das eh
alles nicht so gut beurteilen wie ich
wenn er dann von den Jungs und Mädels
spricht und das wäre ja schön wenn es so
ist aber ich glaube man sieht dann doch
immer wieder dass dass er das eben nicht
unbedingt immer besser weiß sonst hätte
man ja früher Umsteuern können in der
Russland Politik also ist ein Punkte
immer wieder kommt man auch noch mal auf
die anderen handelnden Männer auf einen
Lindner und dann habe ich das würden Sie
denn sagen
also zu Scholz würde ich noch sagen dass
er nicht äh das ist ja keine Typ Frage
sondern eben es ist ein Regierungsstil
den er sich auch abgeguckt hat weil er
erfolgreich ist also so dass an sich
Abblättern zu lassen und möglichst
sozusagen ist ja auch deshalb 16 Jahre
erfolgreich gewesen unter Angela Merkel
weil sie das so vorgelebt hat dass man
so am besten durch die durch solche
Krisen auch kommt
die Umfragen honorieren das nicht aber
trotzdem ist das glaube ich auf die
lange Sicht wird er wissen dass das
immer noch die klügste Methode ist
Robert Habeck dagegen hat versucht sehr
offen zu kommunizieren und auch sehr
offen immer Probleme zu erklären dafür
wurde er dann einerseits vor allem auch
von Journalistinnen Journalisten gelobt
weil er einfach mal mit uns spricht aber
gleichzeitig hat er sich dann eben auch
ganz oft so Fauxpas erlaubt also wo er
dann einfach mal ähm im Fernsehen halt
sagt so ja den 50er kriegst du nicht und
das ist natürlich kommt bei den Menschen
glaube ich ganz ganz schlecht an wenn
sie sehen okay der nimmt das da ein
bisschen flapsig mit dem Geld für mich
kommt es auf die 50 € nämlich sehr wohl
an und ähm wenn er dann natürlich in die
bredoje Gerät und eigentlich nach Katar
fahren muss um da Gasverträge zu
schließen da kommt er auch kommunikativ
nicht mehr durch also das ist einfach
ein grundsätzlich die Lämmer in dem die
Grünen stecken in dem er als auch grüner
Minister natürlich steckt das heißt
diese versprechen kann er eigentlich
nicht einlösen sich von den fossilen zu
befreien und da kann man dann
kommunikativ auch noch so norddeutsche
über seinen Müsli sprechen das neben
einem die Menschen dann nicht mehr ab
das ist dann einfach auch nicht mehr
authentisch und ich glaube bei Christian
Lindner dem ist wahrscheinlich sowieso
am Ende egal was die Menschen von dem
denken weil er hat ja seine lange
Kampagne wo er dabei gut aussehen musste
und viele haben dann über seine Hochzeit
gesprochen und so weiter aber eigentlich
inhaltlich sagte relativ wenig also ich
könnte mich jetzt an keinen Statement
erinnern wo er mal versucht technisch
etwas zu erklären sondern er versucht
sich aber eher so rauszuwenden und dann
zu sagen ja da mussten wir das dann auch
mittragen aber im Grunde macht politisch
ist ihm das glaube ich alles total egal
ob er dann ähm oder sagen so erschießt
noch am meisten gegen die eigenen
Koalition also er ist eigentlich am und
diszipliniert ist und so wie die FDP
überhaupt nicht diszipliniert ist in
dieser Koalition das heißt obwohl sie so
eine die der kleinste Koalitionspartner
ist würde ich sagen hat sie die größte
Rolle eigentlich die machtpolitisch
Rolle nicht nur eher im
Finanzministerium er ist ja an jedem
wichtigen Gesetzes beteiligt gewesen und
das gibt dem eigentlich mehr Macht als
er jetzt den Umfragen nach und auch den
Zahlen nach hätte wahrscheinlich aber
ist denn für sie die stärkste Figur im
Kabinett als außer Herrn Scholz also das
ist natürlich auch
eine Position oder ein Amt das dankbar
ist
das Außenministerium aber ich räume
unumunden ein ich hätte das nicht
geglaubt dass Frau Bernburg dermaßen
sattelfest ist in den Formulierungen es
gibt wenn
infopass einfallen bin ich bin nicht
neugierig aber ich muss sagen insgesamt
ist es schon ein starker Auftritt den
Frau bärburg im Schnitt jedenfalls
hinlegt also ich würde jetzt nicht dass
sie und wir sind sollte zwischen Scholz
und ihr ja oder auch zwischen habe und
ihr auch da gibt's ja gelegentlich
Gerangel jetzt sind wir vielleicht in
den letzten Jahren und fast Jahrzehnten
auch von unseren Außenministern
insgesamt nicht übermäßig verwöhnt
worden da in der Hinsicht aber das finde
ich schon dass das eine an starken
starker Part ist den sie da spielt aber
ich würde gar nicht grundsätzlich
widersprechen ich glaube schon dass es
das ist Augenblicke gab in denen sie
tatsächlich etwas diplomatischer hätte
formulieren können
wenn man zum Beispiel Taiwan mit der
ukrainischen Situation in einen Topf
schmeißt dann wird es halt diplomatisch
kompliziert mit China aber grundsätzlich
glaube ich dass die beiden der
Bundeskanzler und die Außenministerin
einfach relativ gut mit verteilten
Rollenspiel ich glaube ich gar nicht so
dass das dass das so zwischen beiden
abgesprochen ist ich glaube da gibt es
tatsächlich eine eine gewisse natürliche
Spannung weil er die Art Außenpolitik zu
betreiben die die Außenministerin
präferiert gar nicht so gut findet aber
insgesamt funktioniert es ganz gut weil
sie zum Beispiel ausgleicht was dem
Kanzler fehlt was die osteuropäischen
Partner von Deutschland erwarten sind
eben klare Äußerungen in Richtung in
Richtung großland in Richtung Ukraine
und da sind sie nicht immer zufrieden
mit dem Bundeskanzler sind aber
begeistert über das was die
Außenministerin sagt im Endergebnis im
Endergebnis ist das gut ich wollte nur
sagen was Christian Lindner angeht ich
glaube dass er sich das schon überlegt
was er tut er hat natürlich einfach eine
andere Aufgabe weil er das Problem hat
dass seine Wählerschaft seine
Anhängerschaft am meisten fremdelt mit
dieser Regierung seine Aufgabe ist es
diese
Partei in der Regierung zu halten und
möglich sind das darf man ihm ja nicht
übel nehmen bei der nächsten
Bundestagswahl über fünf Prozent zu
kommen und
das tut er glaube ich und das tut diese
Partei in dem sie und das ist ganz
natürlich weil er sagt es ja immer wir
regieren mit zwei linken Parteien indem
sie deutlich macht dass sie sich
unterscheidet das ist andere Positionen
gibt aber ich habe bei ihm nie das
Gefühl gehabt jetzt in dieser Zeit dass
er tatsächlich
spielt mit Drohungen wir könnten da auch
rausgehen er könnte es nicht einmal
nicht gemacht da hat er die Drogen schon
wahr gemacht bevor es losgehen und hat
gesagt lieber gar nicht regieren als
schlecht regieren also eine Absage
damals an ähm an die vorige Koalition
ähm Jamaika und ein zweites Mal kann er
diesen Joker gar nicht ziehen ich glaube
allerdings schon dass er inzwischen
wieder öfter an seinen Satz von vor der
Bundestagswahl denkt dass ihm die
Fantasie fehlen für das zustande kommen
eine simpel dann plötzlich hatte die
Fantasie doch aufgebracht weil er
natürlich auch kein zweites mal sagen
könnte nö wir sind dann doch lieber
wieder nicht mit von der Partie aber ich
glaube dass sie öfter seinen Satz von
damals in Erinnerung kommt dass bald
hier vielleicht drei sogar fast zwei zu
viel sind aber mindestens einer zu viel
in dieser er muss natürlich vermeiden
den Eindruck zu erwecken dass er sich
sozusagen in der falschen Regierung
fühlen ne das ist es gibt keine richtige
er muss vermeiden dass er muss vermeiden
dass das der Eindruck entsteht wir
wollen hier eigentlich gar nicht sein in
dieser Regierung gibt ja keinen es gibt
kein richtiges Leben im falschen so ist
mit dem regieren eben auch ne sie hat am
Artikel geschrieben auch über die Rolle
der CDU ähm wie leicht macht die CDU ist
der Ampel oder macht es Ihnen schwer
Ihre Projekte durchzusetzen
naja sie macht es ihnen schon schwer
natürlich also als Oppositionsführer
glaube ich muss man sagen spielt März
eine gute Rolle und lässt den Kanzler
auch immer wieder blass aussehen bzw
auch umgekehrt glaube ich braucht der
Kanzler ihn manchmal um den Fahrt zu
kommen also wenn wir uns erinnern in der
Generaldebatte wo man dann plötzlich ein
leidenschaftlichen Scholz erlebt hat das
ist ja auch ein bisschen dank märz also
insofern helfen sie sich auch
gegenseitig aber ähm trotzdem ist die
CDU natürlich noch nicht richtig in
ihrer Oppositionsrolle angekommen also
man merkt so ein bisschen märz ist
irgendwie äh als der Hardliner gewählt
worden enttäuscht jetzt seine Anhänger
natürlich mit der Frauenquote mit
solchen Sachen muss natürlich die Lager
verbinden aber blinkt dann trotzdem
immer mal wieder nach rechts und haut
dann sowas raus wie den asyl-tourismus
oder den sozial Tourismus so und das
changiert so ein bisschen und man weiß
einfach noch nicht so recht mit welcher
CDU hat man es dazu tun
Fehler der Ampel nutzt natürlich
geschickt im Alltag aber die Partei
fühlt sich ja auch gleichzeitig etwas
vernachlässigt
hat man ja jetzt beim Bürgergeld ganz
gut gesehen dass die CDU natürlich das
oder die CDU geführten Länder mit der
CDU ist natürlich extrem ausnutzen
werden jetzt wahrscheinlich bei jedem
Gesetzesvorhaben was sie entweder
verspricht in der Öffentlichkeit dazu zu
bekommen oder eben zu stören dass auch
zu tun und da spielte ja auch die FDP so
eine interessante Doppelrolle und hat so
überbande gespielt und gesagt na
eigentlich finden wir so wie das
Bürgergeld jetzt verabschiedet wird auch
gar nicht so gut und haben dann ja quasi
wieder so eine quasi Opposition geführt
gemeinsam mit der CDU zumindest
diskussiv dass man gesagt hat man stört
eigentlich die eigene Koalition dadurch
dass man jetzt gerade beim Bürgergeld
also wirklich an der Stelle wo es darum
geht wirklich minimal den Regelsatz zu
erhöhen für die Ärmsten im Land gerade
da hat sich jetzt die CDU bewogen
gefühlt da müsste sie jetzt Eingreifen
also ich glaube das sagt schon ziemlich
viel darüber aus wie man jetzt diese
institutionelle macht die man seit der
NRW weil jetzt dann plötzlich hat wie
man jetzt nutzt um der KO zu schaden
ansonsten waren es bisher immer
eigentlich reden heiße Luft von
Friedrich Merz dem er die zeitenwände
nicht weit genug ging und so also mehr
gemacht
hier nur reden und heiße Luft also
klassische Oppositionsrolle und da nutzt
er den den Hebel den er hat versucht
aber jetzt wo die CDU den Hebel hat seit
der NRW Walkern sie ihn auch nutzen und
das tun sie jetzt im Unterschied glaube
ich auch ganz dankbar dass er ihn bei
beim Bürgergeld genutzt hat um da den
Teil zu rauszubeinen der wirklich
problematisch war nämlich diese sechs
Monate quasi ähm Quarantäne oder
Ruhezeit das war das Kernstück und in
Wahrheit das tut mir leid und das hat er
auch zurecht deutlich gemacht gingst
dein erster Linie um einen Exorzismus am
eigenen Leib der SPD die SPD wollte den
Teufel austreiben den sie Hartz 4 nimmt
und der ihn da seit Jahren schwer fällt
zu akzeptieren dass der von ihrem
Kanzler kam oder dass diese
Kollegen von ihrem Kanzler kam und ich
finde das nicht nicht ehrenrührig wenn
eine Opposition dann die Machtmittel
nutzt die sie hat um die Korrekturen
herbeizuführen diese notwendig arbeitet
wirklich die Korrekturen also es ging um
50 Euro Regelsatzerhöhung und es ging um
die Schonfrist und das Schonvermögen und
und die Sanktion genau aber ich gebe
Ihnen Recht dass die Sanktionen sind der
Kern eigentlich dieser genere Form
gewesen und die wollte die SPD ja auch
nicht ganz über Bord werfen sondern nur
so halb aber das zeigt doch aber
ziemlich viel über den Charakter eben
auch der CDU die dann genau an der
Stelle angreift wo sie sagt okay gerade
bei diesen bei dem sanktions Regime was
das war was eigentlich das Hartz 4
Gesetz wirklich wirklich am stärksten
gemacht hat wo die Gänge gelungen der
Menschen wirklich am allerstärksten ist
da geht man rein aber eine anderen
Stelle wo es um Milliarden Hilfen geht
da sagt man dann gar nicht so viel dazu
die Koalition jetzt auf den Weg gebracht
hat sind ja doch einige Sache wir haben
das Fachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetze
Lauterbach hat eine krankenhausreform
vorgestellt
und Bürgergeld der Mindestlohn wurde
erhöht er brößler ist da richtig Tempo
drin in dieser Koalition sind das Sachen
die einfach mal abgearbeitet werden
mussten oder wie würden Sie all diese
Projekte bewerten ich würde sagen dass
er zumindest schon einiges an Ambitionen
drin ist und das worüber wir auch noch
nicht gesprochen haben ist was hat diese
Bundesregierung übernommen da ist ja
wahnsinnig viel verschleppt worden über
die Jahre zum Beispiel bei der
Fachkräfte Einwanderung
die SPD hat mitregiert sie hat mit der
Union sie hat mit verschleppt völlig
richtig dass daran will sie jetzt nicht
mehr unbedingt schuld sein aber Fakt ist
es gibt eben da eine neue Mehrheit und
gerade Fachkräfte Einwanderung ist so
ein Thema wo sich zeigt bei allen
Unterschieden dies in dieser Koalition
gibt gibt's eben auch Themen wo die ganz
gut zusammenkommen und das Arbeiten sie
jetzt ab und deshalb sage ich ja auch so
schlecht ist die Bilanz gar nicht neben
der Krisenbewältigung neben dem
Krisenmanagement haben sie zumindest
damit angefangen jetzt wenn man sich so
anschaut was ist aus dem
Koalitionsvertrag jetzt angegangen
worden
gibt es zumindest einen Anfang der würde
ich sagen dem Zeitplan entspricht wir
sind jetzt wir haben jetzt ein ein Jahr
von vier Jahren und sie können darauf
verweisen dass Sie ein paar Punkte jetzt
angepackt haben die Kliniken sind glaube
ich ziemlich dickes Brett dass man da
bohrt auch da sind natürlich alle
verantwortlich die in den letzten Jahren
Jahrzehnten regiert haben aber zu sagen
wir wollen das jetzt anpacken und das
ist einfach verfehlt wie es läuft ist ja
zumindest kein Fehler viele sagen aber
immer es ist nicht schnell genug vor
Gerste wie sehen sie wie finden sie die
Projekte werden zu langsam umgesetzt
weil man ja gerade durch die
Energiekrise ja wirklich ein großen
Druck hat und viele sagen dann auch die
wirken dadurch getrieben ist ja
vielleicht auch ein Problem
naja also ich würde schon auch sagen
also gemessen daran dass diese Koalition
eben überhaupt keine Einarbeitungszeit
hatte keine Ruhezeit sofort reagieren
musste
bringt sie doch einige der ursprünglich
geplanten Vorhaben auf den Weg
gesellschaftspolitisch gab es da ja
einiges natürlich waren es die einfachen
Sachen das waren ja auch die Projekte
auf die sich alle drei wirklich gut
einigen konnten also jetzt
abschaffungsparagraphen 219a oder auch
das selbstbestimmungsgesetz was auf dem
Weg gebracht wird jetzt im
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht das sind so
Sachen da machten macht sie ihrem Namen
fortschrittskonditionen ja durchaus auch
Ehre aber klar ist das natürlich jetzt
vieles anderes im Vordergrund steht und
da kann man natürlich jetzt immer
meckern es ist nicht genug und es geht
nicht schnell genug aber ich finde nach
einem Jahr Bilanz muss man doch auch mal
sagen was gut läuft und ähm die
Gasspeicher sind gut gefüllt die
Deutschen haben einigermaßen klarlos
gespart natürlich hat auch das milde
Wetter gehabt aber der diese Herbst wie
schon gesagt wurde ist nicht gekommen
und das muss man glaube ich alles in
Rechnung stellen und sagen wenn man ins
Ausland schaut England USA Frankreich
dann läuft es doch hier gar nicht so
schlecht wenn das so ist und Sie sind
sich ja da auch ziemlich einig dass
vieles doch ganz ganz gut läuft
das ist eben auch sehr halbherzig also
man kann ja in allen Beispielen sagen
dass es das ist schon von vornherein
schon im
koalitions in der Vereinbarung war es
schon zu wenig und nicht den Namen
Fortschritt Wert also 219a abzuschaffen
bringt überhaupt nichts ohne 218 auch
abzuschaffen also die
illegalen Schwangerschaft Brüche
komplett aus dem Strafgesetzbuch zu
streichen und die materielle
Verbesserung auch der Versorgungslage zu
verändern also das bringt mir jetzt wenn
ich eine schwangerschaftsabzug Abbruch
brauchen natürlich was wenn ich mich
besser informieren kann na klar aber
wenn die wenn die versorgen aber wenn
die Versorgungslage nicht besser wird
dann sozusagen dann merkt man doch dass
man nur den halben Weg gegangen ist und
genauso könnte man das eben an allen
Stellen sagen der Mindestlohn wir vorher
schon zu wenig gewesen unter der
aktuellen inflationslage reicht er
massiv nicht aus genauso beim Bürgergeld
und man kann das eigentlich bei jeder
jetzt
reformpolitischen Frage machen dass es
Dir nicht nur zu wenig ist sondern sage
ich nicht nur weil ich eine linke bin
und das sagen muss sondern weil doch
tatsächlich bei den Menschen zu wenig
ankommt und unter dieser Preiskrise
jetzt noch mal mehr tatsächlich an die
Menschen de facto weniger in der Tasche
als vorher und das kann man doch nicht
sagen dass die entlastungspakete dann
ausreichen ich würde sagen die Gießkanne
ist zwar das falsche Instrument dafür
gewesen ich hätte mir da auch mehr
gezielte soziale Steuerung gewünscht
aber es ist doch so viel mit der
Gießkanne ausgeschüttet worden seid ihr
seid Menschen gedenken hätte ich fast
gesagt nicht also was möchten Sie denn
noch was machen der hat ausgeschüttet
und ausgeschüttet und ausgeschüttet
ausgeschüttet weil er erstens weil
Deutschland das auch können also die
anderen europäischen Länder haben sich
natürlich auch zurecht beschwert weil
die fiskey Regeln für alle anderen danke
Christian Lindner auch ziemlich hart und
das heißt andere europäische Länder
können eben nicht so leicht
entlastungspakete auf den Weg die
Deutschen könnten das gleichzeitig kommt
bei den Menschen nicht viel an weil wie
gesagt schon Dinge verrechnet wurden die
sowieso schon um koalitionsvorhaben drin
waren oder auch weil man jetzt die
Gießkanne ist wunderbar sie kann helfen
aber gleichzeitig müsste man eben die
reichen die man dadurch auch trifft
höher besteuern und das will dann die
Regierung nicht tun und insofern
verteilt man eben Geld auch in die Leute
die es nicht brauchen und da wird es
dann eben sehr sehr ungenau aber unten
ganz unten von denen auch wo die
Kaufkraft wirklich eingeschränkt ist
jetzt da kommt überhaupt nichts an nein
also das können sie nicht ernsthaft
behaupten dass da überhaupt nichts sagen
es gab die 300 € Einmalzahlung es gibt
jetzt im Dezember wird die
Energiekosten werden übernommen also es
ist ja schon ein Punkt ja es wird die
größte Not dass die Leute nicht auf die
Straße gehen wird gelindert ja natürlich
aber es ist doch so wenn sie jetzt
jemanden fragen auf der Straße haben Sie
in diesem Jahr viel weniger als im
letzten Jahr dann würden doch alle sagen
ja ja das ist leider diesen Abend können
was die Regierung gesagt hat du stirbst
gibt also ja wirklich dass er einen
hohen ja der Kanzlerin
und trotzdem kriegen dann diejenigen 200
€ 300 € mehr dass der Punkt
im Prinzip und das das für das alles so
eine Unzufriedenheit dass es eben nicht
so gleich verteilt ist
ja wenn die Frage dahin geht hat das
damit zu tun dass die Menschen ja
eigentlich nicht zufrieden sind mit
dieser Regierung also zeigt sich ja dass
wir hier sagen okay ist ja eigentlich
ganz gut gelaufen aber die Umfragen sind
nicht so und dann hat das glaube ich
zwei Gründe natürlich spüren die
Menschen in ihrem eigenen Leben das ist
nicht besser wird das das ist völlig
klar ich würde da nur sagen es gibt
grenzendes möglichen und ich würde sagen
das was die Bundesregierung jetzt
gemacht hat in den vergangenen Monaten
ist im europäischen Vergleich sehr viel
zu sagen es kann immer noch mehr sein
oder es müsste mehr sein ist eine Frage
der Finanzierung steuererhöhungen sind
mit der FDP nicht zu machen das ist
einfach klar wenn man sagt diese
Bundesregierung soll soll bestehen
bleiben dann wird man sich auf
Steuererhöhungen sollte nicht
dramatisches passieren nicht verständigt
kann man das Durchhalten das weiß ich
nicht weil das ich glaube man kann wir
können tatsächlich
da nicht in die Zukunft blicken und wir
haben ein so dramatisches Jahr erlebt
und wissen nicht ob das nächste Jahr
nicht noch dramatischer wird insofern
ich würde nicht mal Christian Lindner
das sagen können der wenn man genau
hinhört ja nicht mal nicht zumindest bei
der Schuldenbremse die er auf seine
Weise eingehalten hat sagt das weiß ich
nicht ob ich das dauerhaft weiter werde
machen können bei Steuerung nicht gesagt
aber wer weiß aber Moment da ist auch
schon was passiert vielleicht so zu
Beglückung von Frau Schwertner es ist so
eine Stimme leise in einem kleinen
gedruckten versteckt die
Erbschaftssteuer massiv verändert worden
so uns jetzt die Notare nicht mehr
wissen wie sie hinterherkommen sollen
mit den Schenkungen die jetzt noch
gemacht werden weil ab dem nächsten Jahr
die Fachleute damit rechnen dass die
Erbschaftsteuer doppelt so hoch ist wie
jetzt und das ist natürlich eine
Maßnahme die Sie sich wünschen und die
auch gemacht wurde also ganz so ist es
dann auch wieder nicht ich teile hier
einen Punkt insgesamt war zu viel
Gießkanne aber es ist ganz schön viel
Energie rausgekommen
gleichzeitig an ist auch was an die
falschen gegangen und selbst die
Wirtschaftsweisen wenn selbst die sagen
und die sind ja nun wirklich nicht für
wirklich keine berufsrevolutionäre sagen
wir brauchen temporäre Energie Sohle von
denjenigen die wirklich genug haben also
und da sperrt sich die Regierung einfach
dagegen das ist dann also es ist einfach
es ist ein Problem natürlich könnte man
sagen die FDP muss sich da öffnen sie
ist der ideologisch andererseits weiß
die FDP wenn sie das tut jedenfalls zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt tut ist das
politischer Selbstmord weil es geht
nicht um die Akzeptanz in der
Gesamtbevölkerung es geht um die
Akzeptanz der potenziellen Wähler
ein Jahr hinter uns also Frau Gerster
wie stabil ist denn Ihrer Meinung nach
die Ampel hält die durch bis 2024 ich
denke schon dass sie durchhält also wenn
sie dieses Jahr durchgehalten hat was ja
wirklich ein sehr schweres Jahr war dann
glaube ich kann man da schon
vor Hoffnung sein dass es auch noch drei
weitere Jahre hält und müsste sie den
ein oder anderen Ministerin vielleicht
auswechseln
naja also ich glaube
Lambrecht ist natürlich schon die
Ministerin die einen am ratlosesten
macht die wollte von Anfang an nicht
verteidigen Ministerin werden und das
merkt man auch
Lauterbach wird sich noch erweisen ob er
wirklich als Fachmann als Arzt diese
große krankenhausreform durchführen kann
aber ich denke mal ja also
okay was würden Sie sagen was muss
passieren oder was was wäre eine große
Bedrohung das ist nicht klappt naja also
was was was was was Personal angeht da
glaube ich auch dass das eine heiße
Kandidatin verteilungsministerin
Lambrecht ist ähm ich glaube auch gar
nicht dass das völlig unmöglich ist der
Bundeskanzler liebt glaube ich
Überraschung und es könnte durchaus eine
Überraschung sein dass es da irgendwann
zu einer personellen Veränderung kommt
ansonsten ich habe es schon gesagt ich
halte es eigentlich für unmöglich dass
diese dass diese Regierung aufgibt
weil es einfach in der jetzigen Lage
unmöglich ist alles was passieren kann
ist ja dass es schlimmer wird und wenn
es schlimmer wird also wenn die
weltpolitische Lage schlimmer wird und
wenn die wirtschaftspolitische Lage
schlimmer wird wird es ehrlich gesagt
den Druck auf die Regierung
zusammenzuhalten nur noch verstärken
deshalb fehlt mir da jetzt die Fantasie
unter welchen Bedingungen
von Paul zu profitieren
ja also ich fürchte ich weiß nicht ob
Volker auch noch halten kann die
Verkehrsverhältnisse wirklich noch da
gibt man fliegt mit den Grünen aber das
blaukatastrophe aber mal sehen ob das
passiert ähm ich glaube auch dass sie
zusammenhalten wird aber man wird im
nächsten Winter sehen also wenn die
gastspeicher eben nicht gefüllt sind und
der Krieg weitergeht dann kommt glaube
ich erst noch der nächste härtere Winter
auch auf die
Regierungskoalition zu und dann möchte
ich mal sehen wer ideologisch nachgibt
also ich finde auch Gerechtigkeit für
Christine Lambrecht Herr Wissing
fremdelt mindestens im gleichen Maße in
seinem Amt wie die
Verteidigungsministerin in ihrem die ja
auch erst gar nicht Ministerin werden
wollte dann unbedingt Ministerin werden
wollte aber eben auch nicht
Verteidigungsminister
hält und Ministerin auszuwechseln oder
Minister auszuwechseln ist normaler
Vorgang das ist jetzt kein Hinweis auf
die Erosion einer Regierung den
Finanzminister nicht auswechseln
ich bedanke mich für die Diskussion
vorgestern nach Frankfurt Herr Brüssel
und Herr Schwennicke und bedanke mich
bei Ihnen fürs zuschauen das war die
frühlingsrunde in dieser Woche und ich
wünsche Ihnen ein schönes
Adventswochenende bis dann
[Musik]